we have summer sanders on the line
former olympic champion two-time Gold
gold-medal winner in in 92 at the
barcelona olympics summer you on the
line there I'm here and Reggie you
forgot to include most importantly a
team member of Lifetime television for
women wmb a baby you me celaya thousand
and more Driscoll we were the original
commentators for lifetime when the WNBA
the inaugural season so we were a team
but more importantly forget about that
summer taught us to swim at the hyatt
pool in Sacramento top Michelle and I
how to swim officially if you can
believe that in Olympic winner it was so
funny trying to get us to learn how to
float and swim and proper technique
trying to learn for summer so yeah you
have to visualize it the only one had to
swim cap on was Reggie the only one that
didn't need a swim cap was Reggie and I
was the perfect about it that's it we're
just going to stop it right there you
know let's talk about Lily because
you're right 19 so Reggie I was 19 in
1992 when I won I would never have had
to get to do what she's doing and I
think it proves how far we've come
because this year we've been celebrating
the team the swim teams 1976 Shirley
babish I went in to the 1976 Olympics
and was expected to win gold medals in
every single one of her races and she
came home with a backpack full of
silvers and she voiced her concern and
she was nicknamed surely surely it's a
different age it's a different era and
lily is speaking her mind she's got sass
she's relaxed she's real and now should
gold medalist summer we're gonna play
the clip when she talked to Michelle
after her win and I kind of want to get
your thoughts on what she said so so
listen to what she said to Michelle
Tafoya
do cake you made a statement beyond just
your speed and your ability tonight win
an Olympic gold medal it's probably
making the statement though open for you
but beyond that with the feem of a thing
do you think you made a statement on
behalf of the United States and other
athletes you know we can still compete
clean it and do well the Olympic Games
and that's how it should be so summer my
question to you what was more impressive
to you as you said you've walked in her
shoes what she did in the pool winning
gold or what she said out of the pool to
Michele Tafoya well I think it's a
combination red because she had the guts
to say that and I'm not even one hundred
percent sure if she was aware that it
was all captured on video when she was
wagging her finger finger Dikembe style
right um with the fact that she was
asked afterwards and then and then there
was all that build-up to that final so
is the fact that she said it and then
she got in the pool with that fame
relaxed attitude and that focus and she
won and I said it last night on my yahoo
segment there was a point like 10 meters
in the wall and I thought you leah was
catching her and passing her and going
to touch the wall first and I feel like
I felt it from Lily that she was saying
in her head hell no I am getting my hand
on that wall because it meant so much
more than just a moment right it was the
statement it was her voice it was pride
for America and it really was a
statement for all clean athletes Reggie
I've said it all along like here's the
deal there's no black or white you
either are clean or you are cheating and
if you're going up against years the
only thing that you can do is mentally
say there's nothing new people can take
to make them mentally tougher than me
summer that's what really good their
summer can you tell when another swimmer
is cheating could you tell that a theme
of a we know that she tested positive
twice for banned substances can you tell
when another swimmer has taken steroids
I can't I can't anymore reg I mean
there's so many different forms of
pushing the limit you know and he tenido
paying its summer I wanted to ask you
this because we see trash talking going
on in basketball obviously in football I
never knew trash-talking was this big in
swimming last night that the whole
Michael felt and Chad look close the way
he was looking and dancing in front of
them this is the most decorated Olympic
athlete ever and you're out here trash
talking to him what really goes on in
that holding area behind closed doors
you know I'm smiling right now because I
have Reggie Miller talking to me about
trash I love this I love this you mean
you must have been kind of impressed I
loved it I actually loved it the lily
King and I loved it the staredown yeah
yeah no it's here's the deal it's like
it's great TV it's almost as if they get
it you know that their sport does need
to be more than guys with goggles and
swim caps and really big muscles and
swimming in pool this was a great moment
for swimming it's a rivalry and we
haven't seen that for a long time and
and I don't even know if it's that
heated it's just the ready room is so
weird right like where else you have to
sit right next to the person that you're
about to compete again and we have to
fit in there for quite a while and
rotated the ready why are why in the
ready room and they're splashing water
on them and all that what is that for
for us I don't know nervous energy
there's no real reason I to get kind of
used to the water and wake yourself up a
little bit but Reggie know I love you
but I'm at the airport right now and I'm
picking up my kids and they sell them
walk off the plane I gotta go and I love
you and I love America and you keep
sucking on Reggie Miller okay I'll get
you back in the water that's two time
gold medal winner summer sanders thank
you we love you summer oh that is great
running you and I love America I'll see
you later does it get any better than
that the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you